la chaleur prévue dans les transports en
commun on vous l'a dit on attend jusqu'à
35 degrés donc à l'extérieur vous
imaginez ce que ça va donner à
l'intérieur des rames de métro ou de rer
bond est d'autant plus que la plupart
des lignes ne sont pas climatisées en
ile de france
or la ratp et la sncf organise dès ce
matin pour vous aider à affronter à la
canicule avec par exemple des
distributions de bouteilles d'eau va
retrouver ce matin william elle la
reporte rbfm part et vous êtes en direct
de la gare de sainte geneviève des bois
alors comment se passe ce début de
semaine au plus près des usagers
williams
eh bien écoutez il va faire chaud dans
les transports il va faire chaud dans
leur verser bien qu'un tiers des rames
sont équipées de la clim on est avec
frédéric petit à le maire de sainte
geneviève des bois ou ici dans votre
commune à l'entrée du havre hier vous
avez décidé de prendre soin des usagers
oui bien évidemment on sait par rapport
aux températures fortes températures qui
dans cette semaine que les usagers du
rer qui sont à plus de 7000 ici à sainte
geneviève des bois bas vont souffrir
terriblement delà de la température dans
les wagons donc on a souhaité mettre un
point fraîcheur alors ce matin ils sont
pressés et prennent ils prennent les
transports mais ce soir je suis certain
que voilà ce sera très utile d'avoir ce
point fraîcheur c'est petit espace où
ils peuvent prendre un verre d'eau j'en
ai transport à une petite terrasse on
est comme au café on a des fontaines à
eau
est ce que c'est parce que selon vous la
sncf ne prend pas la mesure et ne gère
pas les épisodes caniculaires comme il
le devrait pas du tout mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui le nombre de trains qui
sont climatisés sont trop peu nombreux
voilà alors même si un effort pour
climatiser pour climatiser les trains
aujourd'hui par de forts épisodes de
voile à de fortes chaleurs comme on
comme on nous l'annoncé cette semaine ça
va être terrible parce que l'ensemble
des trains ne sont pas encore climatisé
il va y avoir d'autres initiatives dans
la ville vous m'expliquez tout à l'heure
aussi avec les commerçants par exemple
oui bien évidemment alors on met là on a
commencé à déployer dès la semaine
dernière dans l'ensemble des
ventilateurs dans les écoles on a des
salles climatisées pour les personnes
les plus fragiles
on a un registre où les personnes et je
pense notamment aux personnes âgées
isolées ont pu être recensés auprès du
centre communal d'action sociale on a
des citoyens bénévoles qui
nous aider à aller au domicile de celles
et ceux qui souffrent de la température
et puis j'ai été hier au téléphone avec
le président de l'association des
commerçants de sainte geneviève et on
pourrait essayer de mobiliser aussi les
commerçants de la ville ils sont
plusieurs centaines en leur proposant
simplement de mettre une à deux chaises
dans leur commerce
ce qui ferait autant de points de
fraîcheur qui nous permettrait de passer
cette semaine qui s'annonce terrible
en ile de france merci beaucoup monsieur
faire des pointes fraîcheur il y en a
beaucoup ailleurs la main juste avant de
partir ici avant de prendre l'air
ça fait ch iran nains thibault me that
her là vous le voyez c'est le moment de
prendre une douche ou alors au retour
quand on du travail histoire est bien
d'oublier toutes les effluves qu'on a eu
dans l'air